it's time for roses and Rose a I'm the
color of sunshine but this episode was
about dead dogs hello everyone I'm
Lawrence diamond we were here to talk
about the bachelor in paradise but known
as super paradise the episode because it
was a lot to talk about dog cancer my
dog's been battling cancer for six
straight months I was gonna come here it
and dead dogs a couple months ago my dog
died and she's like my best friend pour
one out for your puppy so diving right
in Ashley I was crying yet again but
this time we learned that it allegedly
wasn't just about Jared it was also
about her dog that died recently I know
that the spirit of my dog Lucy journey
and Ashley said she knows her dogs in
heaven because all dogs fail she learned
that wisdom from the popular 1989
animated film all dogs go to heaven
cheers to Ashley and a child's education
front
oh and the drama kept on coming because
tonight we saw lace and Grant aka
Grace's fight but you realize you were
disrespectful like you were okay so okay
so here's the thing face it's like she
doesn't think that this is real she
doesn't think she's deserving maybe so
she lashed out started flirting with one
of the guys whose names we don't
remember oh that's his name same as mine
ah grant grant grant grant grant grant
grant grant I die for grant grant I'm
dead you're reading my eulogy I'm as
dead as Ashley's dog
oh no z17 grant is the kindest human he
literally said that relationships take
work and that if he has to work a little
bit more than Ashley right now I'm okay
with that because I feel like she's
working because she's worth it am i
crying am i crying
no I've incapable but I would be if I
could wow I just love grant and I think
Greece has a shot what do you guys think
let me know round three of the drama
already not a lot of laughs tonight
mostly mostly drama um now this drama
I'll be honest as much as I love this
show this drama felt a little bit
manufactured the twins go to Nick and
they ask him if he's okay
and his response is pretty robotic yeah
I'm happy how are you feeling as it
should because it was a weird question
it felt like a little bit of planting
basically the twins seem to want to stir
up the Nick and Josh drama again
and sure enough it worked I should say
that's not the way to how to be a man
brother it's not that hard to stir up
about as easy as a white peach sangria
on a summer day I'm just dreaming people
I'm just dreaming I hope you know that
like whatever you would ever say so the
twins get Nick to like say some stuff
these are
that about Josh and then at the rose
ceremony um this was a shocker
they reveal their leaving because they
haven't found love unfortunately which
also means Daniel and a couple other
dudes whose names we don't remember had
to go home
whatever the twins are in tears I mean
they were ready for this exit and just
before they have to leave they go to
Amanda and tell her tell me Astra best
friend they heard some stuff about Josh
and that she really is to watch out for
Josh again this is all stuff we've heard
before do you trust me but Josh Josh and
just trust us Josh for example I am very
frustrated right now
now I gotta say though I have to defend
Josh here ever since I've been here for
some reason one one person or multiple
people have been accusing me of being
like fake I think he was just reacting
to yet again this conversation coming up
and he didn't know where it was coming
from kind of confused right now
I'm confused I'm just confused
eventually Nick owned up to sing some of
the stuff he said and it was Nick V Josh
again and there isn't any evidence that
josh is there for the wrong reasons
there's speculation but that doth not a
confirmed report me and now drink to
round four of the drama Wells arrived
and wells is awesome and Ashley like
dwelling on her Dayton it was great but
then this other girl I think her name is
Jamie she arrived and she wanted to take
Wells I think so would you like to go on
a date with me of course yeah actually
was a sleeve so Wells just went had one
of the day and oh my god when actually
woke up everyone I'd like to Nick to
deliver the news Nick continues to be
this amazing narrator of the show and he
keeps sounding like drop bombs on people
she asked he said yes and I gotta say
Nick please have some babies because you
are awesome you would make a great dad
listen to what he said about Ashley I I
hope this is an opportunity for Ashley
to demonstrate some maturity and growth
yes yes now of course we know she did
not it's still like Caribbean Sea where
our time with the baby no no Ashley did
not display any maturity and growth once
wells was gone she didn't have the
attention from him she put that laser
beam red lipstick focus right back on
Kayla France started to cause problems
there did I bother you in the beginning
of course you did to the point of Kayla
ending the episode saying she is going
to leave paradise
and this was even after Jared gave her a
really sexual but bruise yeah Ashley I
just putting her a little high ponytail
itself in all sorts of situations and I
loved it
also if you were drinking every time
there was a dog in the episode you drank
a lot because man oh man to these
editors throw some dogs in there I don't
know where these dogs are coming from at
one point a dog just went up to Wells
and Ashley's dinner date and they fed it
don't feed that dog you don't know what
that dog has I'm not an animal hater I'm
just anti-rabies thank you okay
so what did you guys think of tonight's
bachelor in paradise whoa let me blow
your mind here for a minute the finale
is next week yeah I know I know I know
again if I could cry the tears would top
roll let me know you think over on
Twitter and be sure to subscribe DTS
youtube channel as we continue to cover
bachelor in paradise and all bachelor
nation shows every week right here I did
not drink nearly enough of this wine let
me like Nick solve a problem
keeping it classy just half the glass
okay have a great night everybody I'm a
journalist I I have a master's degree I
know that's hard to believe